have multiple calls coming from inside
of people that have
barricaded themselves inside the shooter
is inside and just shot at it twice
the call started just after lunchtime a
man with a rifle at a supermarket and
what america's seen so many times before
happening all over again
[Music]
the mass shooting this time at the
king's super in boulder in colorado
more victims of america's epidemic of
gun violence
outside there was a massive police
response many of those who were inside
ran for their lives we just kept going
we just ran and there was somebody
laying in the road
and i was trying to run towards him and
nicholas pulled me away
and he said we have to go and we just
ran
and hid behind the building's other on
the end over here
as the news cameras caught customers
being guided to safety by police
they also captured the suspected gunman
being led away
an apparent injury to his leg there is
no word yet
on any motivation for the shooting among
those who died
was police officer eric talley he'd been
the first to arrive on the scene
my heart goes out to the victims
of this incident
and i'm grateful for the police officers
that responded and i am so sorry
about the loss of officer tally
many who were inside the supermarket had
come for covid vaccinations at its
pharmacy
the pandemic may have replaced news of
mass shootings on the screens of
americans but
like so many places colorado has seen
its share of gun violence
the columbine high school and the cinema
in aurora
we now add this to a depressing roll
call of murder
that this country for all the talk of
gun control is unwilling
or unable to confront greg milam sky
news